Referring back to our formula, A equals P times 1 plus r over n to the nt,
we've seen n, the number of times the interest is compounded in a year, equal
to several different values in our different situations. We've had n equals 1,
2, 3, 4, and 12. And presumably, we could have interest compounded even more
frequently than this. As you've experienced, Grant likes to push limits in
order the maximize the amount of money he makes, and now he wants to know what
would happen if his interest is compounded so frequently That is actually
compounded over and over again all the time. Lucky for him, this sort of
interest setup actually already exists. It's called continuously compounded
interest. If we want to use our good old formula here and keep increasing and
increasing n Do I reach a particular function? Let's see what happens if we
substitute in the values p equals 1, r equals 1 and t equals 1 and then
increase the value of n. Well they just said that p equal to 1, r equal to 1
and t equal to 1. Here's what we have. A equals 1 plus 1 over n all to the nth
power. Now I'd like us to see what happens if we let n increase. Let's plug in
some values to find out. So here's a little table for you to help me fill out.
For each value of n here, please plug it into this equation to find the value
of a that goes with it. Now, you're probably going to get some pretty long
decimals, so I'd like you to type in as many numbers As your calculator will
give you, maybe around ten or so. Remeber you can always use the google
calculator online if you need a different device.